قال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان
بلاده منفتحه على الحوار مع كل من يرغب في
السلام مع مراعاه مصالح جميع الاطراف وفي
كلمه خلال لقائه وفد الوساطه الافريقيه في
سان بيترسبرج اضاف بوتين ان روسيا تقدر
موقف البلدان الافريقيه المتوازن حيال
الوضع في اوكرانيا الوفد الذي التقى امس
الرئيس الاوكراني يضم رؤساء السنغال وجنوب
افريقيا وزامبيا ورئيس الوزراء المصري
ونحن نشاهد هذه الصور مباشره من
حيث يعقد الرئيس الروسي هذا اللقاء مع
الوفد الافريقي نستمع اليها عشر
هذا الانقلاب كان قد دعم من ممولين غربيين
وكانوا يعلنون هذا دون اي خجل بل تحدثوا
عن الارقام التي انفقوها
تنظيم هذا الانقلاب الحكومي
وهذا هذا هذا النظام اليوم هو ممثل لهذا
الانقلاب بعد هذا الانقلاب مجموعه من
السكان الاوكرانيين لم يدعموا هذا
الانقلاب واعلنوا ان
واعلن سكان هذه المناطق انهم لن يخضعوا
للاشخاص الذين جاؤوا للحكومه بعد هذه
الاحداث وكانت روسيا مضطره ان تدعم هؤلاء
الاشخاص وهنا اعني علاقاتنا التاريخيه
العميقه مع هؤلاء الاشخاص والسكان الذي
الذين كانوا يعيشون في هذه القطاعات وطوال
فتره طويله كنا نحاول ان
نسوي الازمه في اوكرانيا بطرق سلميه وربما
كنتم تسمعون عن هذا ووقعنا اتفاقا بين
الاطراف المتنازعه في عاصمه بيلاروسيا في
مينسك
في هذه الطريقه بدات تسويه من ولكن ما
اتضح ان الدول الغربيه التي كانت تدعم
نظام كيف كانوا يخادعوننا ثم اعلنوا انهم
لن يلتزموا بهذا الاتفاق السلمي في منسك
وعلقوا العمل به
ورفضوه بعد هذا يا اصدقائي روسيا كانت
مضطره ان تعترف ما لم نقبل به طوالي ثماني
سنوات
قررنا ان نعترف
بالجمهوريات التي شكلت في اوكرانيا ونعني
دنيسكو
الجمهورتين الشعبيتين
اذا تحدثنا عن الجانب من جانب القانون
الدولي هل لدينا حق ان نقبل
هذه
المناطق وان نعترف بها نعم لدينا هذا الحق
لان الادارات في تلك المناطق على اساس
قانون الامم المتحده كانت كان لهم الحق ان
يعلنوا استقلالهم اذا كان لدينا الحق ان
نعترف بهم لذلك قمنا بهذا ووقعنا اتفاق
صداقه وتعاون على اساس قانون الامم
المتحده وكان لدينا حكامل ان نقوم بهذا
لان نظام كيف قام بمحاولات عديده لكي يحل
النزاع بطريقه مسلحه وهنا بدات العمليات
العسكريه في عام
واستخدمت ضد السكان المدنيين الدبابات
والمدفعيه والطائرات الحربيه هذا ما قامت
به
هذا ما قام به نظام كيف وبدات الحرب
وعلى اساس قوانين الامم المتحده كان لدينا
الحق ان ندافع عن هذه المناطق اساسا على
قانون الدفاع عن النفس هذا هو المنطق الذي
شرحته لكم وهذه هي وجهه نظري ووجهه نظره
زملائي والخبراء
المعتمده على قوانين الامم المتحده هذا
الجانب الاول الجانب الثاني الذي يقلقنا
جميعا هذا مرتبط بالجانب الاقتصادي والامن
الغذائي
وكل ما هو مرتبط بهذا والتضخم وغيره
الفت انتباهكم ان
الازمه في السوق الدوليه هي ليست نتيجه
للعمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا ان
هذه
الازمه كانت قد تشكلت قبل النزاع في
اوكرانيا بكثير ولقد ظهرت هذه الازمه لان
الدول الغربيه الاوروبيه والولايات
المتحده بداوا بالقيام
بحصار
لحل مشاكلهم
وقاموا باجراءات
لحلات المشاكل المرتبطه بانتشار الوباء
وكان هناك نقص حوالي خمس تريليونات دولار
في امريكا وفي اوروبا حوالي 5 تريليونات
يورو وهذه المبالغ كانت قد اشترت جميع
البضائع الموجوده في الاسواق وهذا وضع
الدول الناميه في ظروف صعبه لن اتعمق في
التفاصيل ولكن هذا واقع طبي كما يقول
المثل الروسي اما بالنسبه لاتفاق الحبوب
نعم بالطبع نحن نفهم جيدا انه بالرغم من
كل شيء وبغض النظر عن جميع المشاكل
والصعوبات في الاراضي الاوكرانيه والنزاع
بين روسيا واوكرانيا ان الدول الناميه بما
فيها الدول افريقيا التي تحت
اذا نكتفي بهذا القدر من كلمه الرئيس
الروسيه امام الوفد الافريقيه الذي يزور
روسيا ويلتقي به بسانت بيترسبرج تنضم
الينا من هناك مراسله الجزيره رانيا دريدي
رانيا الرئيس بوتين بدا مرحبا بالجهود
الافريقيه ولكن
نعم فدا بالفعل اولا لا بد من الاشاره الا
نهب بالفعل هذا اللقاء لا يزال مستمرا كان
الرئيس ريسيبلاديمير بوتين قد استهله
بالترحيب بترحيب المبادره الافريقيه
بالجهود الافريقيه لتسويه الازمه
الاوكرانيه اشاره بوتين خلال هذا اللقاء
لترحيب روسيا بكل يعني المقترحات التي من
شانها ان تقوم على اساس يعني على اساس
عادل من شانها بالفعل ان تدعو لتسويه
سلميه للازمات وفضلا عن ذلك يعني اشاد
ايضا بموقف الدول
الافريقيه تجاه الازمه الاوكرانيه ووصفه
بالموقف المتوازن خلال هذا اللقاء اشاره
بوتين منذ البدايه الى انه سيستمع لكل ما
سيفصح عنه القاده الافارقه ومن ثم سيقوم
بشرح وتوضيح الموقف الروسي يعني خلال في
مستهل هذا اللقاء رئيس جنوب افريقيا كان
قد
رسميا ببنود المبادره الافريقيه والتي
تتالف من عشر جنود ابرزها فدا بحسب ما تم
الاعلان عنه خلال هذا اللقاء اولا البدء
بمفاوضات
السلاميه هذه الازمه بالطرق الدبلوماسيه
والسياسيه اطلاق هذه المفاوضات في اسرع
وقت ممكن تحدثت هذه المبادره عن الضمانات
الامنيه لكل الدول دون استثناء اشارت ايضا
هذه المبادره الى ضروره ضمان سياده الدول
وفقا لميثاق الامم المتحده مساله تبادل
الاسرى المساله الانسانيه
تقديم دعم لضحايا الحرب وايضا نقطه مهمه
تم التركيز عليها من قبل القاده الافارقه
وهي مساله فتح الطرق عام امل واردات
الاسمده والحبوب من كل هذه النقاط فدى
تناول الرئيس الروسي
موقفه وموقف موسكو واوضحه للقاده الافارقه
شكرا لك